and rotate has been arrested in Romania  the prosecutors have alleged that Andrew  Tate and his brother are suspects in an  organized crime ring that sexually  exploited at least six women who were  allegedly recruited housed and forced  into performing porn videos for sale  online what was the guy doing in Romania  he lived there okay why did he move to  Romania in recent years which is kind of  a corrupt country that's known for sex  trafficking and all sorts of Nefarious  activities I get that the authorities  are corrupt and the system's designed to  destroy anybody who questions a liberal  establishment and you're gonna die to  him sandwich but hasn't the guy admitted  on camera many many times to running and  only fans agency and to being a pimp to  just put it really bluntly hasn't isn't  that a lot of his career is actually  bragging about being a pimp